翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Ai Tokimatsu
おはようございます
ありがとうございます
はあ ６時間経ちました
私は今日この場所に
「おはよう」という言葉が
言いたくて来たんです
６時間ですよ 長かった
皆さん だから リラックスして聴いてください
私の話は肩肘張って聴くようなものじゃなくて
リラックスして ゆっくり
呼吸をしながら聞いて欲しいんです
そう 私が今からお話するのは
たった３つの
皆が知っていることです
１つは 「おはよう」
今 こんな言葉をいう時間
じゃないっていうことです
もうだって 夕方ですよね？
私は今日 寝起きを想像して
こうしてパジャマを着て
テディベアまで持ってきて
この格好を見た 私の母がひと言
「えっ？おやすみのスピーチをするの？」
違います
私は今から「おはよう」
についてのスピーチをします
私のスピーチで大切なのは
元気に「おはよう」という
たったそれだけです
でもやっぱり皆さん
知っているんです
「え？今さら『おはよう』なんて
言われなくっても知ってるよ」
そうでしょ？だって何年間も言ってきた
訊いてみたいと思います
今朝 元気に「おはよう」って言った人
どれくらいいますか？
おー たくさんいる
（笑）
ありがとうございます
でも 挙がっていない方も
安心してください
今 手をあげてもらいましたが
私は元気に「おはよう」と言えたか
言えなかったということの話をするんじゃなくて
その先の なんで元気に
おはようと言えたのか？
なんで言えなかったのか？
「おはよう」について考えて欲しくて
ここに来ました
そう 考えるということ
脳を使うということです
皆さん やっぱり知っているんです
３つ目です
誰もが ここにいる人はきっと
脳の大切さを知っている
だからこうして たくさんたくさんの
楽しいスピーチを聴いてきて
今も私の話を楽しみにしてくれる
私は今日
「おはよう」と脳の大切さ
その関連性を話しにきたんです
さっき手を挙げていなかった人
すいません
安心してください と言いました
そう 安心して欲しかった理由は
もう一つあります
私はもうずっと「おはよう」
っていう言葉が言えませんでした
え？今しゃべれているじゃん？って
耳や口の話じゃなくって
私には「おはよう」って言えるだけの
元気な体や 人とコミュニケーションする
そういう力がなかったんです
中学のころの話で
私は当時不登校でした
え？不登校？
そんなに珍しい話ではないですよね？
知っていますか？
不登校って今はもう中学校では
クラスに１人はいてもおかしくないと
言われている
これって むしろ 流行っているって
言いませんか？
私 当時 だから流行の最先端だった
このパジャマだから おしゃれに見えません？
この子ともお揃いなんです
ほら ギンガムチェックで
でも これ 両方とも借り物なんです
これは友達に借りて
こっちなんか 私のお父さんのもので
（笑）
でも不登校について皆知っていても
勘違いしている人は実はすごく多い
どういうことかっていうと
私が学校に行けなかったって
いう話を人にします
すると大体みんなこう言うんです
「学校で何かあったの？」
って心配そうに
大丈夫 私 学校で何もなかった
むしろ 学校に行きたくて行きたくて
たまらなかったんです
それなのに 体だけがとても悪くなっていって
学校に行けなくなった
どれだけしんどかったっていう話は
この格好を見てください
私はこの格好が制服でした
セーラー服とかそんなんじゃなくって
一日中これを着て過ごしていた
着替えられる元気や 「おはよう」と
言えるだけの元気がなかったんです
でも そんな状況で 内科に行くんです
あまりにも体が悪いから
何にも結果が出ない
原因不明
原因不明ってなったら
「あれ もう私 心が悪いのかな？」って
「サボりなのかな」って
最初は体が悪かったはずなのに
だんだん心の問題になっていった
そう そうやってどんどん
自分を追い詰めていったんです
今はそんなことないと言えるんですよ
私は当時サボりなんかじゃ絶対なかった
みてください 私 今 すごく元気です
飛び回れる（笑）
でも当時はそんなことできなかったし
どう考えても 当時の私と今の私は
別人のように違う
いま私だからドッペルゲンガーかも
しれませんよ（笑）
けれど でもそんなとき
当時はそんなことなんて思えなかった
なんで思えなかったかって
それ以上考えることができなかったんです
イメージです
私は当時あまりにもしんどくって
頭が動かなくなっていた
私の脳はきっとこんな感じだったんです
みなさん 脳を持っていますよね？
その周りに二重も三重も分厚い膜が覆っていて
それが脳をどんどんどんどん圧迫する
そうなって圧迫していったら
脳は全然動かない
動かそうとしても
それだけでしんどくなってしまうんです
そんな状態で何年も過ごして
中学はなんとか卒業して
高校に進学をして
そんなとき
親が見つけてくれた病院で
私は睡眠障害と診断を受けました
睡眠障害
こっちはもしかして
皆さん あんまり聞いたことがないかもしれない
きっと 明日の朝 みなさん起きて
「睡眠障害」「当事者」で調べてみたら
真っ先に私が出てきますよ
検索してください 私を（笑）
そんな感じであまり知られていなくても
実は睡眠障害も結構数が多いんです
もう不登校とそんなに変わらない
中学生の子供たちが
基準を満たしていると言わている
でも睡眠障害の基準を満たしていなくても
きっと皆さん 睡眠に何かしら問題を抱えている
人ってすごく多いんじゃないですか？
今朝 もうここに来るために
すごく早起きをした人もいるかもしれない
眠い眼をみんなこすって必死に
毎朝学校に行ったり 仕事に行ったりしている
私 学校に電車で行っていますが
きっと皆さん朝 お見かけしたら
皆さんゾンビかもしれない
私もたまに毎朝ゾンビになってしまうかも
なかなか朝一番から元気に
過ごせる人なんていないんです
そう 誰でも睡眠障害になる可能性はある
でもそうやって 誰もがなりうる
可能性があるからこそ
誤解というものが起きます
不登校の時もそうだった
え？たかだか睡眠の問題でしょう？
たかだか学校へいけないだけでしょう？って
努力が足りないんじゃないの？って
実はこれ 言われたんじゃなくて
私自身が一番そう思っていた
周りからそう思われているんじゃないのか
っていう不安が
どんどん自分の心を追い詰めていった
体だけが原因じゃなくなった理由です
でも 聞いてください
睡眠障害はそういった決して
サボりそういった状態ではありません
ただ睡眠のリズムが崩れた
それだけの話じゃない
聞いてください だって私
睡眠障害で半年間近く入院しているんです
眠りの問題でですよ
え？って
私自身が一番ビックリしました
たかだか睡眠で入院？って
そのとき私 入院前に睡眠表
というものをつけていました
自分が眠っている時間を表す
こんな表です
黒いところが眠っているところ
バラバラなのがわかりますか？
ピチピチの16歳の女子高生です
若かった 若いけれど
この睡眠じゃ体が持たない
これを見た当時の私の担当医は一言
これグダグダだねって
ここまでなってしまったら
一人で治すのは難しいんだ
それは 治すのが難しいのは
睡眠障害は睡眠のリズムを整えるだけじゃない
朝「おはようと」言えるような生活に戻すまでに
自分で 脳で考えて治して
いかなきゃいけないからだ
でも 睡眠障害の子供たちは
皆 考える機能が低下している
睡眠障害は脳の機能の障害なんです
そう 私はそうやって入院生活を行って
最初は脳の機能の障害って言われても
あんまりピンと来なかったけれども
入院して行くうちに だんだん朝「おはよう」
といえるような生活が戻ってきました
退院前の私はすごいんです
この夜の10時と朝の7時に
ラインが引いていると思うんですけれど
このラインにずっと毎日
ぴったり 黒い線がそろっていた
毎日毎夜 夜に10時に寝て
朝の７時に起きる
９時間睡眠のこの生活を
ひたすら繰り返していた
睡眠障害の私がですよ
ここの誰より 今の私より
誰より規則正しい生活を送っていたんです
これ おかしくないですか？
私 病気なんですよ
そうおかしいんです
私 睡眠が整って退院しました
でも退院した後も
やっぱりこうなってしまった
あまり変わらないの わかりますか？
ガタガタです
戻っていたはずの睡眠のリズムは
またすぐに崩れてしまった
でもこのときの私は
前の私とは違いました
もうこの頃には もしかして
入れ替わっていたかもしれない
私 ちゃんと学校には行っていたんです
毎日ではないけれど 退院してから
元いた全日制の高校です
戻りました
なんで学校に行けたんだろう？って
少し考えてみると
私は周りの人の支えに気づいたからだって
いうことに気づきました
入院する前は自分のことが精一杯で
そして自分自身で責めてしまうくらい
周りのことが見えていなかった
でも体の調子が整い始めて
初めて心に余裕ができて
周りのことが見れるようになった
すると私の周りには
両親や 友達や 学校の先生や 病院の先生
いろんな人がいることに気がついた
ふと思ったんです
あれ？私 入院中に
一番大切にしていたものは何だろう？って
それはやっぱりコミュニケーションだったんです
それも病院の先生とかだけじゃなくて
同じ病気を持った 同じ睡眠障害の子供たちとの
コミュニケーションが
私をここまで きっと 良くしていった
なんでかっていうと
睡眠障害は体だけの問題じゃない
心だけの問題じゃない
脳の障害なんです
考える力を取り戻すために私は入院していた
それはきっと自分と立場の違う人からの
支えだけではなくて
自分と同じ立場の人たちと
コミュニケーションすることで
もっと良くしていこう 良くしていこう
私たちが自分自身が良くしていくためには
どういう工夫をしていったら
どういうアイデアを出していったら
いいんだろうっていうことを
自分たちでコミュニケーションを
通して考えていったからです
そう 入院で得たものは考える力だった
私は退院してからも聞いていました
入院のときと同じように
みんな退院してからどうしている？って
いまはSNSがすごく便利です
電話でもLINEでも
なんでも聞ける
聞いてみるとやっぱり
皆 退院してすぐには治っていなかった
でも 病気の自分を抱えながら
社会となんとかすり合わせて行こうって
必死でアイデアを考えて
創意工夫していたんです
でも私みたいに
自分一人では限界がある
だって自分の症例しかわからなかったら
どうやっていけばいいのかわからない
だから新しいアイデアを欲するために
同じような仲間たちとの情報交換が
すごく必要だった
だから私たちは情報交換をしていきました
すると私 1年後には
こうなったんです
さっきより良くなっているの
ちょっと わかりませんか？
まだ完全に学校に行けた訳じゃなかった
休む日もたまにはあった
けれども 朝「おはよう」といえるような
生活がようやく戻ってきたんです
ちゃんと退院してからも
そう 私はこれで 無事になんとか
高校を卒業して
ついでにパジャマも卒業して
今 着ているんですけれどね
けれど そして私は大学に
進学できるようになった
大学に進学しようと思ったのは
もちろんしたい勉強があったからなのは
一番なんですけれども
このまま社会に出てしまったら
私はきっとたくさんの健康なみなさんと
闘わなければいけない
もっともっと自分がまた潰れないために
自分のことを考えるために
大学生ならもっと工夫が
できるんじゃないだろうか？
そう思って進学しました
これが今の私です
みなさんの前に立てるくらい健康になっています
医師からも もう普通の人と変わりがないねって
お墨付きまでもらいました
でも私だって100％元気な訳じゃない
毎日毎日「おはよう」って言えるわけじゃない
誰でも そうですよね
皆 常に100％とは限らない
何人かのスピーカーの方が
もう既に言っているように
人間は万能じゃないし
雨の日もあれば 晴れの日もあるんです
だから皆 日々
工夫をしていかないといけない
私は大学に入ってからも工夫がしたかった
今になっても もっと工夫がしたい
そしていま現在苦しんでいる子供たちに
自分が考えている力が
役に立つんじゃないだろうか？
そう思って 「おひさまの家」
という団体を作りました
睡眠障害の当事者の団体です
おそらく全国でここしかないかもしれない
全世界でもここしかないかもしれない
睡眠障害の子供たちはたくさんの苦しみを受けて
心の苦しみ 体の苦しみ 脳の苦しみ
自分たちで考える力を取り戻そうとしている
だからアイデアをどんどん出していく場をつくりたい
そう思って 私は仲間とともに つくりました
まだホームページもないようなちっちゃな団体です
作ってくれる人がいたら募集しています
でも それでも私たちには価値がある
だって睡眠の問題を抱えている人は
こんなにきっとたくさんいる
そう思って今は
NPO法人をめざして活動しています
そう 私は 今きっと創造的に
活動できていると思います
それは何故かって
自分の脳の疲労に気がついて
どんどん自分の脳を守っていこうっていう
方向に考えを変えていったから
この 自分を良くしていこう
良くするためにどうしていこう？
そういう風に考える そんな向上心
きっとみんな持っていると思うんです
私はそんな向上心を
創造性の卵だと思っています
創造性を発揮する前の
その一歩前の段階
自分をもっと良くしようという
それが創造性の卵だと思うんです
誰もがきっと脳の中に
創造性の卵を持っている
でも脳が疲れていたら
この創造性の卵は とても繊細だから
簡単に圧迫されて壊れてしまうんです
そう 私はだから脳の疲労に
皆に気づいて欲しい
皆さん 脳の大切さは知っているって
さっき私 そう言いました
でも脳を使うことばかり考えていませんか？
休めることをおろそかにしていませんか？
自分の中にあるせっかくの向上心
創造性の卵をないがしろにしていませんか？
創造性の卵を守るために
脳の疲労に気づくために
たった１つ とても簡単なアイディアがあります
それが皆さんがもう既に知っている
「おはよう」です
「おはよう」と言える自分を想像してみてください
きっと朝 元気に起きて
人とコミュニケーションとれるだけの
体と心 そして脳がなかったら
「おはよう」なんて元気に言えないし
「おはよう」というコトバについて
考えられないはずなんです
「おはよう」です
試しに私はアンケートを取ってみました
睡眠障害の退院患者の子供達
一般の人たち
合わせて50名に２週間の方たちに
朝「おはよう」と元気に言えるかどうか
そしてそのときの 体や心の調子はどう？
っていうアンケートです
きいてみると「おはよう」って元気に言える人は
体の調子 心の調子がとても良いことがわかった
そうじゃない人は
体の調子や心の調子が
すごく悪いことが分かった
アンケートの感想にこんなものがありました
朝「おはよう」ということで
今の自分の調子に気づけた
なんだか調子も良くなった気がするって
そう 「おはよう」は今の自分に気づくための
そんな簡単な言葉なんです
指標なんです
明日からでも試せる簡単なアイディアなんです
私は今 今日最後のスピーチ
今日の「おはよう」からは
一番遠いところにいるかもしれない
けれど 私 今日 今これで幸せだったと思います
だって私
今日のラストってことは
明日の朝に一番近いところにいる
みなさんの明日の朝のことを
私は考えています
みなさんの明日の朝の創造性と
そして脳の疲労
元気な「おはよう」そんなことを願って
最後に「おはよう」で締めます
ありがとうございました
「おはようございます！」
（拍手）